mr. president concerned by the
prosecutors anything they want to go
back to school and learn because I'll
tell you what the way they treated
people nobody should be treated I don't
want to say that yet but I tell you what
people were hurt viciously and badly by
these corrupt people and I want to thank
if you look at what happened I want to
thank the Justice Department for seeing
this this horrible thing and I didn't
speak to him by the way just so you
understand
they saw the horribleness of a nine year
sentence for doing nothing
you have murderers and drug addicts they
don't get nine years nine years for
doing something that nobody even can
define what he did but everybody said he
put out a tweet and a tweet you based it
on that we have killers we have
murderers all over the place nothing
happens and then they put a man in jail
and destroy his life his family his wife
his children nine years in jail it's a
disgrace in the meantime Comey walks
around making book deals the people that
launched this scam investigation now
what they did is a disgrace our and
hopefully it'll be treated fairly
everything else would be treated okay do
you have any questions on Roger stone
surround Roger stone visit your tweet
political interference no not at all he
was treated very badly nine years
recommended by four people that perhaps
they were no more people I don't know
who they were prosecutors and they don't
know what happened they all hit the road
pretty quickly look you had somebody
just recently you so what happened he
got two months he got sentenced to two
months for leaking classified
information at the highest level who's
that they treated Roger stone very badly
they treated everybody very bad
and if you look at the Muller
investigation it was a scam because it
was illegally set up it was set up based
on false documentation of false
documents you look at what happened how
many people were hurt their lives were
destroyed and nothing happened with all
the people that did it and launched a
scam we'll just call me why where is Co
me what's happening to me Cave what's
happening to Lisa and Peter struck and
Lisa Paige what's happening with them it
was a whole setup that was a disgrace
for our country and everyone knows it to
everyone including NBC which gives a lot
of fake news the fact is that Roger
stone was treated horribly and so were
many other people their lives were
destroyed and it turns out you look at
the FISA warrants and what just happened
with FISA where they found out it was
fixed that it was a dirty rotten deal so
when you look at that and you see what
happened to Roger stone but think of it
a man leaks classified information
highly classified they give him two
months Roger stone for doing nobody even
knows what he did in fact they said he
intimidated somebody that person said he
had no idea he was going to jail for
that that person didn't want to press
charges they put him in for nine years
it's a disgrace and frankly they ought
to apologize to a lot of the people
whose lives they've ruined either next
question of justice or expression
you